I had fun though. You were having
fun, it was weird, Oh, last night.
Last night was fun. That sounds fun.
Yeah, I had a good time. It's just a,
it's a different feeling,
but I think people are feeling
differently about comedy now. Uh,
because so many people are really
politically correct outside of comedy and
almost forced into it.
Like you're hearing so many things about
people getting fired from their jobs
because of sexual harassment or
from a sexually harassing joke.
Like someone would say jokes in the
office that were inappropriate so they got
fired and this is
happening left and right.
You hear about the guy from
Netflix that got fired for doing,
he's having a conversation about offensive
words that you shouldn't be using in
comedy.
And because of this,
this conversation during this
conversation about this subject,
he used the word Nigger,
right?
Because he was in this conversation and
did it one other time apparently because
of that, not calling anybody
to that saying it out loud.
It was fired from Netflix.
That is crazy.
Unless if he was saying it like he
likes having a good time with, right.
Like, he was like, you know,
right now, like how was he saying?
Was He, that's the thing,
right? But the thing is,
it's very strange that that word is only
for bidden by the people that can't,
it can't be used on, right. Like you can't
use the n word on you, it won't work.
But if you can use it on someone and
they happened to be a person of color,
then that person, you're not allowed to do
that. Right. It's very interesting, man.
Well, I remember when I would go,
when I'd ride my bike to school,
a lot of my black friends
or get on my bike, you know,
and they get on and I would ride
them and it was fun, you know?
And they used to call me the Nigga bus
whenever I rolled up and they would all
call me that. And I honestly felt, and
they were my friends. It was fun. Right.
So, but you couldn't say it, you know, and
I could, I couldn't say it. And also look,
I find, you know, when
somebody says anything, if it's
something to do with a race,
uh, gender, anything, and they have
malice or ill intent and these days,
I think if you do that, somebody's going
to correct you really fucking quick.
And so I agree. And in a bit,
but in a business setting, man,
and that type of setting,
it's just, yeah, you,
you make people so aware that they can't,
I don't know. That's the fuck it is.
It is crazy. But it's also, he was
talking about forbidden words in,
right? It's his business.
But you're saying he can't
make a sound with his mouth.
This is what you're saying. You're not,
he's not calling someone that name. Right.
He's using that word and people file
complaints about him using that word so
that people that he worked
with ratted him out.
Like he wasn't just allowed to say
the word. Right. But the cra then,
then it gets real crazy.
Whereas if you're a black guy,
you could say it all day and it's funny.
Yeah.
You could say it in front of white
people and they can laugh. Right.
But they can't say it, but they
can't say, they can't say it. Yeah.
But have you Chris Rock,
you can go up with the orr tonight and
just have like 15 different use of that
word in a half hour set. Yeah. And No.
And everyone's like, that was great.
That was a great show.
Right. But then, yeah,
but then it'll be the same people that
say we should never say or hear this word.
It's interesting. Some people
learn it from different places,
some people learn it from black people,
some people learn it from white
people and has a different feel,
a different meaning to it. Well,
and I was even talking with them,
Mr. Peterson the other day,
um, who I was saying, you know,
the toughest thing I find is,
especially coming from the area
walk came from were, you know,
there was a lot of racism
was probably kind of went to,
it was popular when I was young,
but it was a part of the,
it was part of the t of the cloth in the,
in are in the area, you know, is poor,
black and poor white. And you know, poor
people like to fucking fight, as you know,
it's cool. It's everything.
It's like, yeah, it's like, hey,
let's be on the same team for a minute.
You know,
and we can change the love that you have
about white privilege. Oh, thanks, man.
Hilarious bit. Thank, but did you.